well hopefully you took the time to
celebrate as Monday marked the 5-year
anniversary of the Jesse Smet hate crime
hoax and I say that with some hesitation
because I know that there's really not a
single living person whoever wants to
hear the name Jesse Smet ever again
every detail of that story has been
covered every joke that can be made
about it has been made but if there's a
silver lining in that whole episode it's
that everybody on the planet received a
crash course and how easy it is to lie
about quotee unquote hate crimes you can
come up with the most rid ridiculous
story imaginable and people will buy it
the media especially will buy it and
they will repeat it that was the moment
that hate crime hoaxes peaked you would
think so if you're a rational person you
might assume that post Smet the number
of reported hate crimes would go down at
least a little bit after all the gig is
up you know no one's ever going to be as
naive as they were back in 2019 ever
again but that assumption as logical as
it might seem would be very wrong just
the past year there's been a rash of
cases just like Smets complete with
outlandish claims that don't make any
sense which the media buys without any
hesitation whatsoever and there's so
many examples that you know it's hard to
choose but but here's here's one of the
best ones last summer there was The
Curious Case of Scott Rowan who uh told
reporters in Southern California that he
was set on fire on the sidewalk because
he's gay which raises a whole lot of
questions that the media never asked
here's how the gum shoes at the local
ABC affiliate covered that story watch a
routine walk turned into a nightmare for
a Southern California man 39-year-old
Scott Rowan went to a restaurant in his
San Diego neighborhood to inquire about
a job he says he heard two people
yelling homophobic slurs at him so he
yelled back Roman who was gay says the
next thing he knew he was being dowed
with some sort of liquid and then set on
fire immediately after that I just I
went up kind of like Kohl's on a
barbecue recently just went in into
flames they were obviously out targeting
LGBT community Rowan suffered second
deegree Burns mostly along his side and
back not clear if he'll need surgery he
says this is definitely a hate crime and
he filed a police
report now you'll notice that there's no
effort whatsoever to verify this guy's
story to recap we're told there was a
gay guy who was out for a routine Walk
in San Diego whatever that means on his
way to a restaurant uh when he heard two
people yell homophobic slurs at him
because obviously anyone could tell this
guy was gay from a mile away he's just
walking down the street and of course
there there are a bunch of an
anti-lgbtq assassins roaming the streets
of Southern California on the hunt for
anyone who looks gay so uh you know so
they can set them on fire which like
would seem to mean that they've been
setting a lot of people on fire in
Southern California but naturally in
response this gay guy yelled back at his
as salance and then to his horror he
noticed that he had been doused with
some kind of liquid and uh and and set
on fire literally the only Innovation
over the Jesse mlet hoax in that whole
story is the bit at the end about
getting set on fire and everything else
from the stuff about the restaurant to
the number of asants to the slurs it's
pretty much identical in fact this claim
is perhaps more similar to the story of
a biracial woman named althia Bernstein
in Madison Wisconsin and maybe you
remember her she claimed uh that she was
DED with lighter fluid and set on fire
by a gang of white racists who accosted
her while she was waiting at an
intersection authorities opened a hate
crime investigation into that alleged
attack and then quietly dropped it a few
weeks later saying only that they
couldn't prove that the event had ever
occurred at all which is odd considering
that it supposedly happened at an
intersection in the middle of a city
with dozens of cameras all around but to
give Scott Rowan some credit you know we
do know that he was indeed actually set
on fire there's no denying that he's got
the burns um so so there's an ounce of
believability at least to one aspect of
this story he was set on fire somehow
and uh you know if you don't look into
any of the other details uh or or
inspect it in any way whatsoever then
maybe that's enough for you and of
course the news media uh the news of
this alleged hate crime went viral in in
leftwing circles antifa went wild with
it Etc unfortunately for the narrative
though the the truth eventually did come
out uh precisely three days later I want
you to watch as the same crack news team
that brought you the original story
pulls what maybe the single biggest
about face in the history of Journalism
was watch police say a man who says he
was attacked and burned in an alleged
hate crime is suspected of assaulting a
pregnant woman earlier this week Scott
Rowan who is gay told us he was set on
fire in a targeted attack in San Diego
investigators paint a different picture
they say they got a 911 call that night
of a Man attacking a pregnant woman she
was bleeding and had several injuries
requiring her to go to the hospital an
hour later officers got a report of a
man saying he'd been set on fire
officers determined the man with a burn
injuries was the suspect in the attack
on the pregnant woman then they say she
retaliated using a fire using fire as a
weapon against him so far no one has
been
arrested okay well that's uh a little
different so instead of two homophobic
bigots trolling the Streets of San Diego
looking to torch some random gay guy now
we learned that the gay guy was actually
beating a pregnant woman to the point
that she was bleeding and had to go to
the hospital and while she was being
attacked she somehow set the gay guy on
fire in self-defense now you note how
the news station is not ashamed about
any of this they don't apologize to
their viewers for airing a completely
false story with no vetting whatsoever
that's because they don't care their job
and the job of corporate media in
general is to stoke as much division as
possible if they get caught in a lie
then they'll just strug and move on to
the next one and yes they did
participate in the LIE even if they
didn't they they may not have known that
this really stemmed from an attack on a
pregnant
woman but these are I mean these may be
relatively mid IQ people but but they're
not uh mentally brain damaged absolute
morons so they would have they would
have known that there are plenty of
aspects of the story that are dubious at
best what do you do if you're in the
news media and you hear a story like
this some some guy comes to you and says
that he was set on fire in in in San
Diego by by some uh some some anti-gay
bigots who just happen to be like
roaming the streets and looking for
people what do you do if you can't what
you don't you don't report it at all
until you can conf confirm the details
of the story that's what you do if you
actually care about accuracy and
Reporting but uh of course they don't
now fortunately for the news media there
have been plenty of other fake hate
crimes for them to talk about so they
can always just move on to the next one
there was the case of the 20-year-old
Ohio man who claimed in November to be
the victim of an anti-palestinian hate
crime and here's how the C Council on
American Islamic relations or care
described that episode they said the man
quote uh was walking home from eating
lunch when a car slowed down and rolled
down the window the driver of the car
allegedly started yelling at him using
anti-palestinian statements like kill
all Palestinians and Long Live Israel as
he swerved his car to intimidate the
victim the driver then allegedly turned
around and hit the man while shouting
die you know coming home from
restaurants and and stuff like that has
proven it's a very dangerous thing if
you're if you're on the left I mean
these people are getting assaulted all
the time on their way home from
restaurants now for good measure K
posted a picture of this guy in a neck
brace in the hospital just to underscore
how islamophobic this country has become
as you may have guessed um none of that
was true police later obtained video
evidence that the man's injuries
resulted from a fight with his brother
earlier in the day confronted with the
fact that they were completely wrong
about this supposed hate crime care did
not admit their mistake they didn't
offer any explanation for the decision
to amplify a clearly fraudulent
narrative instead they said this quote
our understanding is that the brother
has secured their own legal counsel we
do not yet know anything more about the
nature of the charges
that was their statement not we're
horrified we misled the public about a
brutal hate crime that didn't happen
just he's got a lawyer so you know we're
not talking about it anymore moving on
for the fifth consecutive year abortion
Remains the world's leading cause of
unborn mortality even despite the
overturning of roie way tragically it's
been reported that the number of infant
deaths caused by abortion is greater
than the number of deaths attributed to
the next seven causes of death combined
pre-born is leading the charge to turn
this around every day pre-born Network
clinics rescue 200 Unborn B by
introducing a mother to her child via
ultrasound a baby's chance of survival
could double I was just kind of like
Lord if this is you know if this is the
way you know let me know if this is not
the way Give Me A Sign you know before I
walk through these doors and I was as I
was getting ready to walk up the steps
and touch the door knob you know a
guardian angel and he just told me he
was like baby you don't have to go in
there and he was like I know someone
that can help him just to see the
development of a baby that small and I
say baby because I mean he had little
arm arms and legs and I mean you know it
was actually a human you know and to see
that and to have that physical and that
contact once you look at that I think it
just pulls on your heart a little
pre-born work has only begun by the time
I finish this life-saving message two
unborn babies will be aborted in this
country will you join pre-born and the
Matt wall show and make 2024 the biggest
baby saving year in history one
ultrasound is just 28 bucks and $140
will offer five babies a chance at life
just style pound 250 and say the key
word baby that's pound 250 baby or
donate securely at pre-born docomo
that's preborn
docomo again there's never any remorse
from these Liars probably because they
can't even tell how ridiculous they look
they're so far gone that they don't see
it remorse requires shame and
self-awareness and these people have
neither of those that could explain the
recent Stunt by California congresswoman
Barbara Lee who as I mentioned before we
played this video on the show a couple
weeks ago launched into a bizarre story
on CNN recently about a supposed racist
incident that occurred at the capital
and if you missed this uh let's watch
that again racism institutional racism
is in the DNA of this country when you
look at uh what has taken place look at
the our Native Americans the genocide of
Native Americans when you look at what
is taking place as it relates to
African-Americans uh the 250 years plus
of enslaving African-Americans and then
you look at the disparities now uh in
our community in terms of health care
unemployment the wealth Gap housing you
can't tell me that systemic racism does
not exist it's not just a little King
secondly you have personal racism which
is hard to address but I'll give you one
little story that shows you why uh we
need to understand that I don't think
she really understands racism I was
walking from the house building on
Capitol Hill to the capl and a man a
white guy stopped me and told me I could
not get into the members elevator and
you know we have uh pens and I was going
going to vote and he blocked me from
getting into the elevator and told me I
was not a member of Congress and it was
for members only I said sir I'm a member
of Congress and he I showed him my pen
and he said whose pen did you steal now
this is an example of what personal
racism is and how people of color
constantly have to deal with this each
and every day yes well I mean at least
he didn't have lighter fluid on him you
know so that's the one good thing but
once again right away you know nothing
makes sense about the story and you
could tell she's lying because she
leaves out the kind of details you would
need to verify the story she doesn't
tell you when this incident happened uh
which would allow Capital police to pull
up the surveillance tapes in about 10
seconds and conveniently she doesn't
offer any description of the white guy
like who is he is he a police officer is
he a random vigilante patrolling the
elevators of Capitol Hill to make sure
no black congresswomen get inside we
have no idea and she didn't mention it
because this is all made up like all
these other recent hate hoaxes it just
makes no sense and by the by the way she
has also just moved on from that she
never came she never circled back around
to say oh well here's some more
information about that you know let's go
find no just move on to the next thing
and I could go on and on and on listing
dozens of fake hate crimes that have
been reported over the past year but the
data tells the story we are indeed
witnessing an epidemic of fake hate
crimes uh in the postlet post BLM era as
many news organizations reported this
week the FBI has determined that from
2018 to 2022 hate crimes in the United
States have increased by a staggering
60% and if that sounds bad rest assured
we're told that it gets even worse the
problem is especially acute among
students the bureau tells us in that
same period from 2018 to 2022 according
to the FBI reported hate crimes in
schools and colleges have doubled nearly
doubled Elementary and secondary schools
are the hot spots we're told supposedly
the most common hate crimes in schools
are anti-black hate crimes followed by
anti-jewish followed by anti-gay anti
anti-white hate crimes don't make the
top three despite the fact that white
kids are the victims in nearly every
video of an assault at a school by One
race against another that we've seen in
the last 10 years there may be a couple
of exceptions to that and I'm just going
to grant that there probably is a couple
I can't even think of any almost every
single video you
see is like this for example I want you
to watch this footage of a recent
beating at a school in Florida which
again comes to us from a local ABC
affiliate and notice what's not
mentioned
in this report here it is Police closing
in on suspects after a brutal Beatdown
near margerie stowman Douglas High
School and viral video shows a teen
pummeled in a parking lot before he's
picked up and slammed to the ground
local T crime specialist Bridget matter
live now in Coral Springs with that
investigation
Bridget and the students seen in this
brutal video they have been identified
and police are working to make those
arrests the victim here has suffered a
skull fracture and was
hospitalized disturbing cell phone video
shows the brutal beating of a student at
North Community Park in Coral
Springs eventually some witnesses step
in to
help another angle of the beating shows
the students slammed to the ground all I
could think was these people are animals
what prompted the fight is
unknown so and that's not a fight by the
way that's you know 10 people stomping
the hell out of one person that's not a
fight that's just a that's an assault
that's attempted murder
so there was a brutal beating of a
teenager in a parking lot at a school
the victim suffered skull fracture you
had to be hospitalized the motive we're
told is
unknown just no way to explain why this
might have happened what's not mentioned
in the report conspicuously enough is
that the teens who beat the student were
black and the victim was white and just
in case you think that this was another
innocent mistake by the local news crew
rest assured that the national media did
precisely the same thing Fox News
reported on the incident as another
example of quote juvenile violence
that's rocking the nation juvenile
violence nothing else can be said about
this form of violence and and who's
committing it and just juvenile that's
it but the cause of the brawl we're told
is unknown so it's clear that when black
people beat up white people at school
then the identities of the attackers
isn't something you're supposed to talk
about talk about the national news media
doesn't think it could possibly be
related to the motive even though we all
know what they'd be saying if the races
were uh flipped around the other way
given all this there's obviously a lot
of Reason To Doubt the FBI's latest hate
crime data nobody wants to talk about
anti-white hate crimes even when they're
occurring on
camera so we should expect some Under
reporting in that area but for just a
moment let's take this FBI reporting at
face value right and and assume that
indeed there's been a dramatic rise in
the number of hate crimes in schools
let's just pretend right let's live in
that fantasy world for a second well if
that's the case then it would seem to
suggest that our schools are an even
bigger disaster than than we thought
test scores and student productivity are
going down we already know that and they
tell us hate crimes are going up now
considering that schools have never
focused more on preaching tolerance and
diversity this would mean that their
efforts to bring about racial Justice
have been a catastrophic failure and are
doing more harm than good you'd think
that you know that realization might
prompt some self-reflection from the
activists who've been lecturing us for
years about the importance of Dei and
racial Reckoning and so on turns out
none of it's working just like
affirmative action this Grand social
experiment hasn't solved any of the
problems that it was supposed to solve
and that's according to the people who
who you know came up with this
plan and in this case that's certainly
the implication of this FBI report if we
assume it's accurate but the truth is
that the FBI report is not accurate just
like all the reports of hate crimes from
2016 weren't accurate back when we were
told that Donald Trump was emboldening
white supremacists or whatever the
moment you dive into the specifics on
hate crime stats you realize what a
fraud it is the only way this stuff
works is if you never look even an inch
below the surface and as soon as you do
you see that it's there's just nothing
there it's empty now all this data is
based on reported hate crimes so the
media will say hate crimes on the rise
but what they often leave out especially
in the headline is that no reports of
hate crimes are on the rise and that
that part is
true in other words if somebody tells a
teacher that they were called a mean
name because of their skin color that
would count as a reported hate crime
doesn't matter if there's no conviction
or even an arrest all it takes is for
somebody in a police department
somewhere to code an incident as
potentially related to hatred whether
they can prove that the incident even
happened that but that's it and by the
way the police are incentivized to do
this by the Biden doj the doj awards
millions of dollars to local police
departments that report hate crimes so
there's a massive gap between reported
hate crimes and hate crimes that
actually result in a conviction and
what's funny is that you never hear
anyone talk about what exactly this
difference is I mean none of the media
reports this week even mention it I went
through several media reports about The
reported hate crimes and the numbers
well okay well how many convictions have
there been how many of these cases have
actually been
proven now if you go on the FBI's
website you're not going to find that
information either at least not
prominently but I went looking for it on
the website of the California Department
of Justice and I thought this would be a
good state to check since it's one of
the most left-wing states in the entire
country if not the most leftwing so we
can assume that they're going to
vigorously prosecute as many alleged
hate crimes as possible here are the
most recent numbers we have in 2022 the
state of California reported a whopping
2589 hate crimes depending on your
perspective in a state of 40 million
people that might not seem like many but
let's pretend it's an alarmingly high
figure you know just for the sake of
argument well guess how many of the
those reported hate crimes resulted in
hate crime convictions according to the
California doj out of
2589 supposed hate crimes in a state of
40 million how many of them were
actually proven in accord well the grand
the answer is a grand total of 53 so
that's roughly 2% of
them 98% of them in a state that again
is incredibly incentivized in many
different ways to prosecute as many of
these as they possibly can 98% of them
never proen in a court of law many of
them there was never even any charges
brought and again this is in the
jurisdiction where the prosecutors are
presumably the most aggressive on
charges like this and where juries are
extremely predisposed to convict and you
can reproduce numbers like this in any
state in the country there's a massive
Gulf between reports and charges of hate
crimes and an even greater one between
reports and
convictions obviously that's because
most of these reports are nonsense what
we actually have is a massive epidemic
of false hate crime reports that are
eating up who knows how much law
enforcement resources and law
enforcement
time now it's tempting to dismiss all
these reports as hoaxes you know and
it's easy to say that all these reports
are are for mentally imbalanced cynical
people looking for attention or sympathy
or something like that and undoubtedly
that's a big part of it but that's not
the whole
explanation I mean a lot of these people
claiming that they're victims genuinely
believe they are we've raised a
generation to see hate crimes everywhere
everybody from from law enforcement to
Academia to the corporate press have
participated in that indoctrination so
the truth is that this epidemic of false
reports is as much a product of hoaxes
as it is of brainwashing and that's why
we shouldn't be surprised that the
numbers are going up it's also why we
shouldn't be remotely shocked to learn
that ground zero for these reports are
schools and
universities indoctrination is their job
five years after Jesse Smet safe to say
that they've gotten very good at it if
You' like to see what else have to say
you can access my full show by going to
dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
wall Show Twitter page hope to see you
there Godspeed